est-ce que ça ouais c'est bon ça marche
bonsoir
donc moi je vais vous parler un peu du
de la place du design du rôle du design
vis-à-vis de la contribution comment
est-ce que le design peut dessiner
concevoir des objets qui vont permettre
une certaine contribution ensuite
rapidement donc je m'appelle xavier au
fret je suis designer avant j'étais
ingénieur en télécom est parmi les
raisons qui m'ont poussé à m'orienter
vers le design principalement je
souhaitais exercer un métier avoir une
approche qui se préoccupe avant tout des
des personnes des humains pour pour
lesquelles je travaille c'est aussi
sûrement cette double formation
ingénieurs et designers qui m'a amené à
avec deux collègues gamme attaqué à un
sujet à cheval entre l'ingénierie et le
design en proposant un ordinateur
contributif donc je vais vous expliquer
alors un ordinateur c'est quoi
pour beaucoup un ordinateur c'est ça ou
ça à des tours ou parfois ça des
coordinateurs dans de grandes salles
bref souvent ce sont des boîtes noires
c'est assez obscure pour la plupart
d'entre nous en tout cas
et sinon ça peut être ça aussi ça ce que
vous voyez c'est un ordinateur dans un
bidon alors c'est pas évident de
comprendre cette image mais il suffit
d'imaginer qu'on accorde un clavier un
écran une souris à ce bidon à
l'intérieur il y a tout ce qu'il faut
pour jouer le rôle d'un ordinateur
cartes mères disques durs alimentation
son nom est gerry qui est fait dans un
jerry khan
c'est un ordinateur à faire soi même il
a été conçu pour ça et aussi à faire à
partir de matériaux informatique de
récupération
mais avant que d'autres puissent le
faire eux mêmes et il a été conçu par
par trois jeunes designers lors chem
saisine et moi-même dans le cadre d'un
projet à l'école de design industriel
même si les ateliers à paris et en
partenariat avec une start-up hedera
technology donc il a été conçu pour être
pour être simple à fabriquer pour être
évolutif et surtout appropriable vous
avez uniquement besoin de ce qu'il ya là
pour pour fabriquer un jerry et bien sûr
aussi d'un mode d'emploi qui est
disponible en ligne et que nous avions
réalisés en même temps que le premier
prototype alors c'est un projet on peut
le présenter de plein de façons
différentes
on peut parler du problème du recyclage
des déchets informatiques c'est un
ordinateur qui est fait à partir de
rebuts informatique qui leur donne une
seconde vie
on peut parler aussi des problèmes
d'accès à l'informatique d'accès à
internet et des disparités à travers le
monde
mais aujourd'hui je vais plutôt vous
parler d'une des missions principales du
design à savoir donner les moyens de
mettre les mains dedans donner les
moyens à d'autres de contribuer ensuite
et jerry est un assez bon exemple de ce
que peut être le rôle du design
pour dessiner des objets qui permettent
de contribuer parce qu'il a été dessiné
pour être accessible compréhensible et
aussi pour éveiller une certaine
curiosité donner envie de découvrir
d'apprendre l'informatique et tout ça on
a pu le vérifier lors d'ateliers avec
des personnes on a pu on a pu vérifier
que les gens se l'approprient y est
détournée modifier les principes
d'assemblage
on a pu aussi vérifier que son physique
un peu décalé qui est très différent des
boîtes noires habituel des ordinateurs
ce site n une relative curiosité bref on
a pu vérifier que c'était bien un objet
qui permettait à d'autres de contribuer
de mettre les mains dedans et qui
permettait une certaine contribution
ce qui m'amène justement à ce thème de
la contribution qui est un sujet qui
m'intéresse beaucoup aujourd'hui dans
mon travail
alors c'est un terme qui est qui est
très à la mode
on entend beaucoup parler souvent on
prétend mettre l'humain au coeur
permettre une certaine émancipation des
individus mais est-ce que contribuer
c'est positif parce que c'est toujours
le cas et quelles sont les modalités
d'une contribution souhaitable positive
donc la contribution ça peut être
quelque chose de positif mais on a
tendance aujourd'hui à oublier parfois
le côté un peu le côté fort c'est la
contribution les impôts sont une forme
de contribution les travaux forcés sur
une forme de contribution
alors je ne nie pas du tout l'intérêt
l'utilité de
de payer des impôts se questionne juste
ce qu'on met derrière ce terme de
contribution et je souligne tout
simplement que une contribution n'est
pas forcément synonyme de créations
d'émancipation qu'elle peut aussi être
subis recaptcha aussi est un dispositif
contributif je pense que tout le monde
connaît un peu maintenant les systèmes
de cap-chat son système où ces systèmes
où vous recopiez des chaînes de
caractères des formes et ça permet de
vérifier que on n'a pas un automate un
robot qui fait des requêtes sur le web
avec recaptcha vous avez deux chaînes de
caractères déformés et bien la deuxième
va une des deux provient de livres
scannés que les algorithmes de google
n'arrive pas à lire n'arrive pas à
comprendre n'arrive pas à transcrire
automatiquement alors ils vous font
travailler gratuitement
ils vous font contribuer c'est de la
contribution alors c'est pas dramatique
il n'y a pas on va dire il ya pas mort
d'homme y'a pas coercition mais on peut
se poser la question de savoir est ce
que c'est vraiment une contribution qui
permet de s'émanciper
on peut se poser la question en plus si
vous discutez avec avec quelques
personnes vous verrez que peu de
personnes savent vraiment ce que fait
recaptcha qui sont en train de
travailler gratuitement pour pour google
en voilà une contribution automatique un
peu forcé près ce n'est pas vraiment
émancipatrice il ya donc des quatre
contributions un peu extrêmes qui sont
pas forcément positif et à l'autre
extrémité il y à ce que des objets qui
sont absolument pas contributif quand on
les voit on pense absolument pas au
terme de contribution ces objets là moi
je les appelle les objets de confort
sont des objets où tout est décidé réglé
par exemple le modèle nespresso est un
objet entièrement automatique où il ya
plus vraiment de
de réglages bien sûr vous pouvez
toujours choisir entre café l'umq a fait
court et parmi un ensemble de capsules
mais qui sont déjà pré sélectionnés vous
avez pu vraiment de plus vraiment de
choix fin beaucoup moins de choix mais
en contrepartie vous avez un bon café un
confort d'utilisation
quand vous avez un bon café qui est
accessible pour n'importe qui donc on
voit que des fois à ne pas contribuer à
voir moins de choix c'est aussi ça peut
aussi être quelque chose de positif
d'agréable donc est-ce que la
contribution est quelque chose de
systématiquement positif on a vu que non
pas tout le temps par exemple recaptcha
quand recopier machinalement les chaînes
de caractères en même temps on a vu que
ne pas contribuer
ça pouvait être quelque chose de positif
d'agréables alors dessine ton des objets
confortable pratique qui permet d'avoir
un bon café mais qui réduisent un peu le
choix ou dessine ton des objets
contributif mais parfois un peu forcé
quoi contribution en quelque sorte
autoritaire et le rôle du design que je
vous soumets aujourd'hui c'est justement
consiste en un entre deux entre le fait
de ne pas contribuer et une contribution
autoritaire donc on voit que la
contribution la limite entre la
contribution et le confort elle n'est
pas évidente
elle est floue la limite entre un
contributeur est un usager est flou
aussi entre un contributeur qui est
quelqu'un d'actif qui agit en quelque
sorte sur ces objets est un usager qui
va plutôt se servir d'un objet qui a un
usage précis déjà prévus on voit qu'on
peut contribuer de manière un peu un peu
idiotes donc déjà pour moi ce qui pose
un problème c'est le choix c'est ce qui
manque dans les exemples que je vous ai
présenté avant on est forcé de
contribuer où on est forcé d'utiliser un
objet d'une certaine façon
alors qu'on devrait pouvoir passer d'un
comportement d'un rapport actif à nos
objets un rapport passif en plus passif
plus de l'ordre de l'usaj quand on
souhaite c'est ça qui est important
selon moi un bon exemple pour illustrer
ce propos c'est l'appareil photo
certains appareils photos en tout cas
l'appareil photo c'est un objet qu'on
peut qu'on peut régler face auxquels on
peut faire des choix ou pas si vous
réglez un appareil photo en mode
automatique
vous allez avoir un rapport plus de
l'ordre de l'usaj
pouvez vous laisser vous laisser guider
un peu par par l'automatisme c'est un
objet qui permet qui permet les deux
permet de choisir de régler ou de se
laisser porter est ce ce type d'objets
comme l'appareil photo hd s'appelle des
objets inachevé parce qu'il revient à
celui qui s'en sert qui va l'utiliser de
l'achever en faisant des choix en fait
est le rôle du design que je propose
c'est de concevoir ses objets ses objets
pardon inachevé des objets qu'ils vont
qui vont permettre un choix ultérieurs
et aussi parfois le choix de se laisser
porter un exemple qui peut illustrer
c'est bien cette notion d'objet inachevé
c'est ce projet de leur architecture de
lagence élémentale en 2008 la demande du
gouvernement chilien était de reloger
une centaine de familles dans les mêmes
5000 mètres carrés qu'elle occupait
illégalement depuis 30 ans avec un
budget très bas et ils ont construit ça
donc quand on regarde ça on se dit c'est
un peu sec c'est un peu brute c'est
c'est inachevé mais là dedans il ya tout
ce qu'il faut pour vivre pour habiter on
va dire dignement il ya une salle de
bains une cuisine les raccordements
électriques et finalement les habitants
progressivement on fait des travaux
selon leurs priorités leurs préférences
leur choix ils ont complété un objet
inachevé donc ces objets inachevé il
faut les les incarner les concevoir
c'est une des missions essentielles
selon moi du design en proposant
d'autres façons de
de faire et avec le recul c'est un peu
ce qui s'est passé je pense que c'est ce
qui s'est passé avec jerry jerry pour
moi c'est un objet inachevé au début on
a tout simplement proposé une autre
façon de faire un ordinateur une façon
de faire un ordinateur imparfaite mais
pas un parfaite dans le sens mal
dessinée mal conçu inconfortables ou
fragiles imparfaite car à part faire
sans cesse par d'autres personnes et en
regardant les résultats au quotidien
c'est aussi satisfaisant que surprenant
et je vais vous montrer quelques
réalisations de contributeurs dont qui
ont modifié
jerry après voilà donc là on voit
quelqu'un qui ajoute le wifi à jerry en
lui faisant des petites antennes ont
d'une façon assez assez amusante mais
aussi assez efficace ici on voit des
personnes lors d'un atelier à en algérie
travailler sur la charnière de
de gerry ils ont modifié le système de
charnières qui en avait fait au début
nous on coupait entièrement le bidon et
on faisait une charnière cousu et on
voit qu'ils ont laissé une petite bande
de plastique qui permet de solidifier la
charnière c'est quelque chose qui a été
trouvé après par d'autres personnes je
suis lors qu'il aura amélioré et
finalement le plus le plus surprenant
c'est d'observer à quel point les gens
qui font des ateliers ont ce désir de de
personnaliser leurs objets
quand c'est possible ils personnalisent
leurs objets qu alors que c'est assez
rare de pouvoir personnaliser un
ordinateur aujourd'hui à ce point voilà
donc là on voit comment les gens
personnalisent leur ordinateur quand
c'est possible quand un objet le permet
les gens personnalise selon leur leurs
goûts leurs préférences leurs besoins
aussi avant de terminer je voudrais
remercier aussi l'ensemble des personnes
qui font vivre le projet aujourd'hui
parce que bien sûr au delà de des
différentes remarques je vous fais sur
sur le rôle du design il faut
reconnaître que nous avons eu la chance
de rencontrer les bonnes personnes qui
portent le projet qui continue à porter
le projet aujourd'hui en france et dans
différents pays
voilà donc jeu voici donc quelques
quelques éléments de réflexion sur le
rôle du design vis-à-vis de la
contribution alors c'est une réflexion
qui est en cours qui est imparfaite qui
est inachevée mais j'espère que keller a
suscité un intérêt et
et que et que deux que certains d'entre
vous auront à coeur de continuer cette
discussion à propos du rapprochement
entre la contribution et le design je
vous remercie